I Drive on John Dickinson 95 7 the game
a lot of the conversation coming out of
this one will be that you got that you
guys may be sacrificed tonight in some
sense to be healthy for the next four
games if it goes that far do you view it
that way one and you having to win three
of the next four assuming you guys do
get healthier on Friday night I don't I
don't view it as sacrificer we went out
there and played hard when we lost you
know we didn't go in this game thinking
we're not gonna play clay or Kevin or
moon or anybody else and we're just
gonna get his game away today they
played well they'd knock down I think 17
threes you gotta get them credit but we
didn't sacrifice you don't sacrifice a
Finals game to be healthy for the next
one
does anything happen but the same time
you do have to be smart you know we
would much rather have clay for the rest
of the series and putting them out there
and lose them and then nothing
so no no one sacrificed again Marc in
the third row dream on mark Schwartz
ESPN Kyle Lowry
really kind of seemed to turn it on to a
new gear tonight
what tonight what kind of tone do you
think he set for the team and how
different was his performance in this
game then earlier in the series I think
he made more shots than he's made you
know obviously he was way more
aggressive I've been he's been but he
made shots over here a dream on Cameron
Buford um can you talk about how you
guys combat their size and length
advantage that it's here to seem to
impact the game tonight oh we got to be
more solid with the ball and it starts
with me then I've had a bunch of
turnovers and I think every game is
serious so just take you know be more
cautious with our passes you know I
think you know they do have a lot of
length but you know we got to play in
more space and not you know play in a
crowd Trey Marsh in the back draymond in
the back a rash medallion with Sports
Net
just how depleted does this situation
become
Clay's out when loonies out when Katie's
out when DeMarcus is banged up just just
how difficult is it without everybody I
mean is it
it's more difficult than with them you
know I think that goes without Sam but
nonetheless we got guys they can step up
and we just didn't play well enough
tonight so this is what it is
right here next get him in the middle go
ahead
CJ Peterson San Francisco Examiner
German obviously the you know absence of
clay and obviously Durant had been you
know played up a lot but how big was
missing Kevon Looney as well I kind of
threw off the center of rotations a
little bit you guys played Andrew Bogut
over 20 minutes tonight how big was not
having Kevon out there
I think Bogut played great in his
minutes you know but you know obviously
Lorne has been great for us all year so
you know not having him out there
definitely makes a difference you know
not having different because there
everyone when you assemble the team
everyone brings something different so
you know but no one you know no one care
you guys are hurt guys are hurt
everybody want to see us loose so I'm
sure people are happy to hurt we just
got continue to battle and what our Anto
win Game five come back to Oracle win
Game six and then celebrate a break fun
times ahead
Jana policy Eagle News Philippines how
has this finals been challenging this is
a great team you know anytime you make
it to the finals you're playing good
against another great team so you know
it's always going to be challenging you
know to challenge you you know you know
we can sit and talk about the injuries
till we're blue in the face it's not
gonna change how Kevin can feel or how
loonie what's called ya know I was like
some costal cartilage fracture something
like that it's not gonna make that feel
better
anything gonna make clay hamstring feel
better either so you know it is what it
is with the guys we got out there we got
a roll with and you know we fought
tonight we lost we're gonna fight again
I don't really see us losing too many
more dough but we gonna fight again so
is what it is and then Steve last two
in Killian with the San Francisco
Chronicle point of the Raptors defense
Steph still set a playoff personal
playoff record for himself and Steve
said he he does things that he doesn't
think anyone in history has ever done
what did you think about his performance
tonight he was amazing you know I got to
play better and offer him more help I
think if I play better with the night
that he had we were denied he had we
wouldn't want so you know we need him to
continue to be aggressive like he's been
and you know all of us to learn to be
better and like I said that that starts
with me you know if I was better we
probably would have won that game but he
was he was amazing tonight not that you
know he's not know amazing pretty often
but tonight was a special performance
for him I mean he definitely does stuff
that and I don't think we've ever seen
anyone ever do and we probably won't see
anyone ever do it again Steve last one
on the side burner nba.com if ever there
was an if ever there was a night to use
a box in one this would seem to be it
regarding staff so with with the Toronto
defense focusing on him did you see him
have to do more than usual and and what
sort of things were they doing to try to
stop him I think you know they were
throwing bodies out of thinking I might
have talking to nurses off the box and
one you know he folded under pressure a
little bit I think I'm just playing for
now you know they definitely do bodies
at him and you know we got to do a
better job of when they're throwing two
and three guys at him a coverton I don't
think we did a great job of that tonight
and you know we usually take advantage
of those situations we didn't you know
when we're better doing that you know
you make them play let me make them pay
for the way they're playing hit get
stuff so we got to do a better job of
that and you know get off floor spacing
and guys I don't think it was agreed
tonight